[Music]
countless kids grew up with a christmas
story and have gone from watching it
with youthful wonder to seeing it
through older wiser eyes
in celebration of that inevitable shift
in perception here's a look at things
only adults notice in a christmas story
one of the hallmarks of a christmas
story is the rich fantasy life that
ralphie indulges in on his road to
christmas day
and hopefully his red rider bb gun the
most elaborate of these fantasies
involves him
imagining what he might use the gun for
as bandits led by black bart
attacked the family home forcing ralphie
and his trusty new weapon to defend his
family
it plays out like the perfect kid
fantasy of a western in their very own
neighborhood but it takes a slightly
dark turn when at the end it's pretty
clear that ralphie has killed black
bart's gang
kids might not notice this but the
lulling tongues and crossed out eyes
suggest death and he was after all
shooting them
yes it's just a fantasy but it's a grim
one for a kid who mostly just wants to
shoot targets in the backyard
ralphie is nine years old as most of a
christmas story unfolds placing him in a
rather interesting in between age
he's young enough to still consider
things like christmas and santa claus
the most
important parts of his life and to care
deeply about things like little orphan
annie's secret decoder rings but he's
also old enough to fancy himself more
mature than his younger brother
it's subtle but this budding maturity
comes out in a couple of key moments
when it becomes clear that ralphie is
becoming interested in women
when the old man sets up the leg lamp
for the first time ralphie basically
cops a feel of the thing and in both his
fantasies and in real life
it's clear that he at the very least
wants his teacher to like him
he might even have a little crush on
miss shields
ralphie's quest for his red rider bb gun
culminates when feeling
all of the adults in his life have
forsaken him he decides to appeal
directly to santa at the local
department store on christmas eve
this backfires spectacularly as ralphie
spends the entire time waiting in line
trying to focus on his goal only to
forget everything he was going to say
when he finally climbs the towering
north pole structure
to make matters worse the santa at the
top seems unusually intimidating and
even frightening to ralphie's eyes
as he panics amid a closing store and a
group of pushy elves
it's clear that ralphie blew his shot
but what's less clear is why
what about his past history with santa
made him so nervous about asking for
something from the big guy
was he just psyched out by all of the
rejections that came before
or is it more specific a christmas story
is a tale of kid concerns and kid
perceptions
so everything in ralphie's world is just
a little bit heightened
this includes his encounters with the
bully scott farkas who seems to lurk
around every corner and takes his sick
delight in the pain of other kids to
near supervillain levels
at least until ralphie finally finds it
within himself to fight back
to any kid watching bullying is if not a
reality at least a familiar
abstract concept they've had to deal
with in their lives so they may simply
accept it and move on with the story
for adults though there's a sense that
the bullying in a christmas story
is particularly dark in part because the
adults surrounding the children don't
really do that much about it and the
kids don't necessarily want them to
farcus haunts ralphie and his friends
all the time but they don't tell on him
flick walks into class with a black eye
one day and miss shields pays little
attention to it
even when ralphie finally beats the hell
out of farcus his mother ignores the
other kid in the fight and focuses only
on her son
never really stopping to ask what
happens it calls to mind a world in
which kids are entirely on their own and
to modern audiences that can be a little
scary
ralphie's father only ever referred to
as the old man is a typical
representation of a midwestern father
figure in the early 20th century
he's stern but not cruel caring but not
affectionate and distant but not
absent he's a man's man and he spends
most of the film
just trying to read his newspaper and
enjoy a little bit of turkey while his
sons get into trouble around him
if you look close enough though there
are little hints of eccentricity in the
old man's life
he insists on being timed when he
changes a tire for example
and went through the trouble of burying
his major award in the backyard and
supposedly playing taps in tribute to it
as he did
he even takes some time in the
department store to skip along with the
wizard of oz characters
ralphie doesn't think much about it but
there's more to his old man than
newspapers and furnace battles
he has a rich inner life that we only
see glimpses of
despite being a ubiquitous movie there
are still things about a christmas story
that some viewers can't agree on
a key point of contention comes midway
through when the old man's beloved major
award is broken
and he's unable to glue it back together
the mother readily admits to breaking
the leg lamp but claims it was an
accident that happened while she was
watering plants
some viewers believe her while others
think that she did it deliberately
because she was sick of looking at the
thing
and indeed she does confirm she thinks
it's
the ugliest lamp i have ever seen in my
entire life
so what really happened look at the
expression on her face just as she heads
into the front
room with her watering can knowing she
will be alone with the lamp for a moment
and listen to the sheer force of the
breaking sound
she definitely meant to do it these days
we think of christmas as a season that
begins roughly at the end of
thanksgiving
a period of weeks packed with
decorations shopping seasonal
programming
and all manner of parties and other
events the way ralphie obsesses over
christmas in the film you'd think that
it would be similar for him but
in the 1940ish era in which the film
takes place that's just not the case
for the parker family christmas as an
observable holiday really only lasts a
couple of days
they go and get the christmas tree then
christmas eve arrives shortly thereafter
and the family packs in a parade
shopping decorating and visits to santa
all in one night
there is no black friday no long period
of shipping gifts to the front door
no early december christmas parades and
no long slog of christmas parties to
march through on the way to the big day
the parkers basically wait until
christmas as a day to arrive
and then celebrate it's not a huge plot
point and kids might not notice it but
adults whose entire schedules are thrown
out of whack in december definitely do
the leg lamp in a christmas story has
become so iconic that it's almost more
famous than
any of the film's actual human
characters but until it arrives at the
parker's residence it could be anything
the old man comes home from work one day
says he's going to be getting a major
award that very night
and then a crate shows up ah
fragile it must be italian
well i think that says fragile honey oh
yeah
before it does though the old man is
just musing aloud about what the award
might be
and even dares to think that someone
might be sending him the d to his very
own bowling alley
this raises a couple of questions what
does the old man do for a living and
what on earth did he do to earn a major
award that could range from a weird
novelty lamp all the way to a piece of
commercial property
we don't learn much about the old man's
work and the fluidity of this moment
and what exactly might have happened
just further underlines a common kid
truth
they often don't really know what their
parents do all day
when the hard midwest winter comes in a
christmas story ralphie's mother bundles
up
randy in such a way that ralphie even
compares it to deep sea diving and randy
famously complains that he's wearing so
many layers that he can't put his arms
down
once outside randy can't even get up off
the ground by himself because his
movement is so hampered
it's comical but it also makes you think
of what exactly was supposed to happen
when he got to school
randy couldn't very well pull all of
that stuff off by himself so who is
doing it for him
more importantly who is rebundling him
when it was time to go home for the day
somewhere in that school there's a poor
employee who had to be on randy parker
winterwear duty day after day
and they very likely weren't happy about
it the old man in a christmas story has
many different nemesis
there's the furnace that won't stop
acting up in the basement the oldsmobile
that won't run right
and of course the dogs next door we know
very little about the bumpus family in
the house beside the parkers
all we really know is that they have a
lot of dogs and those dogs really hate
the old man in an
almost pathological way they follow him
from his car to his door
try to push their way into the house and
ultimately devour the family's turkey
when the doors left open
just enough for them to get through and
wreak havoc
dogs will be dogs of course but the film
doesn't tell us what else is going on
that allows this to happen
why hasn't the old man marched over and
had it out with mr bumpus
of course the plot answer is so he still
has to do battle with the dogs but it's
hard not to wonder how things got this
bad in the first place
a christmas story is a film that depends
in many ways upon seeing the world from
ralphie's point of view which means that
our perspective on the various other
members of the family is slightly skewed
and emphasizes ralphie's father more
than his mother frequent re-watching of
the film reveals especially to an adult
audience that mrs parker is in fact
a much bigger part of ralphie's
emotional memory than we give her credit
for
yes she's there for him after his fight
with farcus but she's also a tender
presence in other ways
she leads the silly christmas carols in
the car has an innate understanding of
how randy's mind works
proves she has the most patience of
anyone in the family when it counts and
even reveals a moment of real tenderness
with her husband in the film's final
scene
mrs parker is much more than a put upon
wife and mother within this story
she has in many ways an inner life
that's just as rich as her husband's
one of the most famous scenes in a
christmas story is the moment when
ralphie makes a mistake and utters the
curse which the movie renders
as
[Music]
this moment and the resulting fallout is
mostly about ralphie getting punished
for cursing in the first place and then
blaming it on his friend
something a lot of kids have no doubt
done but while the kids are busy
relating to the punishment phase of that
story the adults are probably paying a
little more attention to the way
ralphie's mother reacts
a christmas story is a pg movie so we
don't hear too many curses thrown around
but
ralphie makes a point of telling the
audience that he's heard that particular
bad word frequently from his father
something schwarz's mother even guesses
over the phone we as an audience also
hear mr parker's nonsensical cursing
wafting up from the furnace throughout
the film
so we can guess at what else he might
say in other situations
why then does mrs parker seem to have no
clue as to the kind of words her husband
might use in a high stress moment
whatever's going on there this family
has an unhealthy relationship with
profanity
and they need to all get on the same
page check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite christmas movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you